here's an interesting thing so people
are commenting on the coasters
yeah yeah
they love the coffee table they love it
that that is an awesome they're very
upset that there were no coasters
oh they weren't using so is that why we
have coasters now um
well tim hale
says maybe there's no table and that is
just a really big coaster
he's doing jokes
i like that joke because that is that's
that's just
coasters savages
idiots who said that uh dez oh damn
smash adams says where are the coasters
what the [ __ ]
right now
zg says they keep the humidity at zero
percent so they don't have to worry
about condensation
[Music]
we did sort of talk about my dry lips on
the last one
joe joestar wants to know do we do you
even respect
wood yeah do i respect wood
no that's uh are you that's one
thing
yeah
are you serious like are you here here
we go
megan's working yeah megan's work it's
just the bros and you almost weren't
here yes but here you are here i am i'm
literally in wardrobe of of mythicquest
yeah it's exciting so your guy dresses
not dissimilarly to the way you dress
well the sneakers i i think yeah these
are um
i've got a it's sort of like a cult
leader look
oh that is a very culinary look
leader would probably have their own
type of sneaker yeah right
well no they were just the heavens yeah
the heavens gate heavens guys they they
all were nike high tops did
yeah that was part of getting into the
through the gate
i guess you know when when they were all
lifted to heaven you know if somebody
caught you with a pair of adidas on
they'd be like
no you know and we and you know what the
funny thing is we act like that's
ridiculous
as if all the other funny hats and weird
[ __ ] that people wear for other
religions that have been around for
thousands of years parties
choose
what i mean yeah
exactly
like there's that like heart god
dress you of a lot of religions where
it's like make sure you wear a hard
dress shoe in a very thin sock yeah
what's with the thin socks what's with
the thin sock man people are going to
freeze to death
their toes are going to fall off yeah
yeah i forgot a lot of cold countries
here where they're
demanding the thin socks thin sock and a
thin shoe or just cover yourself in
fabric just be draped in fabrics and
fabrics and fabrics why did god want you
so fabric covered
he definitely want you bedazzled oh lots
of jewels yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
certainly on your hats the leaders on
your hands the whales
want you covered in jewels and some gods
want you in no jewels and just sort of
drab meek robes and yeah
can somebody explain i don't really
understand this bible verse and you you
you did you went to a school where you
know yeah you guys studied a lot and i i
went to church a lot but i didn't
actually study it in school
um the meek shall inherit the earth yeah
i would have thought that it would have
been the rich shall inherit the earth
the meek
are going to do great in the afterlife
because i thought that was the whole
thing i think it's also a part of the
promise when the meek when the meek were
like wait a second we got the numbers
and then yeah the the the strong were
like well no the people in power were
like no you have the heaven and then and
then they're like okay that's good and
that worked for a while and then the
meek were like but can we have it here
too and they were like [ __ ] all right
let's just promise it to him yeah yeah
right let's talk a great way to stay
rich is to tell a poor person that the
best thing you can be is poor me yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and you will eventually inherit the
earth
no no no no no no no not today
maybe after you're dead
um maybe
generations from now yes your meek uh
grandchildren um but the problem is
inheriting the earth that's like that's
some serious wealth and then you're no
longer meek so it's also a lot of
responsibility yeah
like how does that work how does that
world shake out once you've inherited
the earth you're no longer [ __ ] man i
used to be meek but i have the whole
earth now yeah and now i can't it's
tough to stay meek and now i can't go to
heaven so i'm i gotta i should just give
it bro you still meek oh man sold out he
ain't meek anymore he's sold out
he's got the earth and [ __ ] yeah that's
i feel we we were meek before megan made
us do the ads and now we're not getting
air stronger
now we have inherited the earth um
another very manipulative one where the
rich people are like hey listen
i know it looks like i've got everything
going for me and and i do
but
it's gonna be really hard for me to get
into heaven
yeah you know so once i die that's where
this whole thing falls apart for me
and everything is you know great great
for you so my advice to you you stay
there my advice to you would be stay
under my shoe yeah
you know what i mean
yeah yeah basically just figured out i
like that you what's hard to figure out
which parts um metaphor and which parts
literal and that's the fun of the bible
is that like it was all when it was
written it was all literal and then
slowly over time slowly over time that
part's
a metaphor clearly clearly yeah where's
the bible land on ghosts i was thinking
i was having a conversation about ghosts
the other day well the ultimate ghost
right is is i mean he's part of the holy
trinity
the holy ghost i gotta think about
ghosts
so you know a lot of people believe in
ghosts and that's fine but like that's
fine
that's fine you know like
teach throne
but they only believe in like human
ghosts right people aren't like man i
saw the ghost of a worm the other day
and it freaked me out you know what i
mean don't hear a lot of that the ghost
of a worm now is your point uh why is it
that only humans have ghosts and why is
there not a ghost of a worm kind of
arrogance there i think uh and maybe
kind of blows the whole theory up that
like they're only only human souls can
be trapped and walking around maybe
people are like oh i saw the ghost of my
cat yeah like maybe but like at what
point did they stop it's like i killed
the fly and then an hour later i saw the
ghost of that fly and it came back to be
like i wasn't ready to die a tragedy
happened you know like there's a great
idea in this and i love it you never get
that yeah yeah this this seems like a
good uh that's for the race for the
writer's room i don't know we could put
it in sunny you're thinking all right
this is
a good segue into some fun
fun things i came and i saw a ghost i
saw a girl
yeah who was it it
and you know he's i guess he's in
purgatory you know we yeah he can't pass
to the other side until i make peace
with this tapeworm
yes
yes yeah that's a that is that's a good
jumping off okay all right and then you
get the whole like para normal people
which are fascinating yes trying to
it's also great to call them in and then
reveal to them once they're there with
all their equipment that it's a that
it's a tapeworm they're looking for yeah
yeah yeah they're like wait what yeah
and then they they have to explain that
it's only and then you find it and then
they have to confess like look this
whole thing was kind of a fraud but now
i'm not so sure because i
i saw jerry i'll be honest with you the
only ghost i've ever actually seen is
was this tapeworm that you spoke
yeah they have to admit it yeah i've
guys i've heard segwaying a little bit
i've heard from a number of people out
on the street or even people at work at
this other show that i do um or on the
weekends i was at disneyland this past
weekend
uh i do another show yeah on apple
called mythicquest oh [ __ ] that's
exciting
congratulations disneyland was a good
time uh disneyland was amazing
you went to disneyland i went to
disneyland okay yes with some with some
friends and it was amazing and there
were so many people there obviously it
was disneyland and i heard over and over
and over again loving the podcast
love in the podcast good okay and i
always ask people what it is that they
like about it just because i'm
interested in it and yeah 90 of the
people say that they listen to it on the
way to work
yeah i hear more listeners than
uh than i hear creeps but i know you're
out there because we see the numbers
you're watching
um people listen to us on their way to
work and they're on their way home from
work and it's and it feels like they're
hanging out with their friends hanging
out with their buds yeah and i like that
because i feel like i'm hanging out with
my friends well we are
i have more fun on the podcast having
conversations like this because i feel
like i'm talking to my friends as
opposed to talking about the episodes
themselves you know i recognize the fans
do like yeah and it is interesting and
boy this this one uh is a heck of an
episode
uh yeah and uh how do we talk about it
how do we yeah well we could i we can
say this again
making sure that this podcast does not
become the uh an apology tour because
that's just going to get boring and
there's no need for that either but we
have recognized that at the time we
truly felt um that that was that that
was a word that was used commonly and
that made sense well well but it was
also a word that was abused by people
who
you know are awful people yeah our
characters are awful people yes but this
was used because where it totally it
deviated from the characters to the way
that we were using it so casually
it to me made it feel like the
filmmakers us at the time yeah were not
conscious of
what we were saying and how pain painful
that could be for people because it is a
derogatory term that is we didn't know
that at the time well i mean that is
correct
it was much more commonly used at the
time let's face it yeah and then i think
over the what has it been a decade more
way longer yeah since since we did since
we did that
it's become 15 15 years dude 15. yeah
it's become you know we've as a society
said let's let's get rid of this term
but by the way if you recall we weren't
even going to have person in the title
we were going to say sweet destiny yeah
yeah and our word yeah it was almost
yeah but then what we what we realized
was
at the time that was the derogatory
and we did use it and the character did
use it in the episode once uh which was
the abbreviated version of it but when
we titled that
it's different because that's the
filmmakers titling something right right
but then but what we thought at the time
was that the full word was something
that was acceptable even in the
community right as being and it wasn't
until later when we realized that that
was not the case and i think culturally
we it was accepted as well so it is what
it is but ultimately the the characters
get their comeuppance for
using the word so liberally and and
asking a little kev
and then he eviscerates them yeah
and yes and that's why continually when
we're asked hey
how do you get away with this or
whatever the we recognize that our
audience can watch something and
recognize that it's of a time and place
and that they know where we stood at the
time and where we stand now and that's
how we get away with it yeah yeah yeah
we say it a lot in the episode oh yeah
yeah each time i yep me too just just
cringe a little bit right like just
feel it go up here you're just fine so
much great stuff in the episode yeah
it's super funny i mean that's really
sweet
it's really funny i mean kyle's kyle's
amazing is amazing can you imagine
anyone else playing that part i mean
kyle
completely nails that role
yeah he was like a skateboarder
and he he
had something with his eyes blind in one
eye right like he'd had an accident oh
something yeah i don't remember what it
was that happened but yeah and he just
dove into that character and nails it
walks that fine line of you can't tell
if he's yeah if there's something going
on there
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well the whole
episode was born out of us always never
wanting to make fun of people with uh
developmental disabilities but it was to
make fun of uh rappers who
had that affected especially white
rappers that had that affectation
and we had heard a few and i love eminem
it wasn't really eminem it was a couple
of like
low-grade m ms that were coming out
around the time
and
you couldn't understand what the what
the [ __ ] they were talking about right
interviews and things like that we're
like oh
they sound
it does fill in the words and so
let's go let's have a go at them yeah
what if what if there was someone like
that and we weren't sure yeah
yeah i mean it's one of those premises
and he's go gold digging he's clearly
gold digging through the whole
whole episode yeah which is a lot of
love like that that i say that he really
is
you know i don't want to use the word
but that he really is you know and then
later i'm like okay fine he what he's
not he's not and she's like why would
you do that and then she leaves and i'm
like and and you guys are like what so
he wasn't so he's not and i'm like i
don't know who he is yeah yeah he
definitely is he definitely oh no he
definitely is yeah yeah well that's
that's funny that was a good joke what
are you gonna do that's a good job it's
funny but that's super [ __ ] funny and
yeah i think it's okay like
if we had to do it now you know we would
the characters would dance around the
usage of the word and it would be just
as funny yeah and you know so those are
the adjustments you make but like the
characters would would be like
not wanting to say the r word but that
was the intent and you could make a joke
out of that but yeah or we would have
you know a character amongst the group
who was like that's not please don't use
that word you know what i mean like
there would be an opposing view right
i mean i think you can still like
you know we have to still be able to
tackle these kinds of subjects and and
everything but uh you know again i think
we're a little bit more conscious of
making sure that it's clear that we the
filmmakers are not like biased
but what's also interesting what's so
damn funny is the other storyline you
know with everything from starting a
band to the spandex to the day man song
like and do you remember when we cut it
together where we were like well we
dropped the ball on this one and just it
doesn't why do we feel that way well i
can't remember why we thought that way
as opposed to the one we just watched uh
two ago the gang sells out
uh which i feel like totally holds up
i feel like this one
even just narratively is so silly
whereas the gang sells out is silly in
the way that sonny is but you understand
everything and why it's happening and it
all makes sense this is clearly us in
the writers room being like you know
what let's just justify them getting
into a band it makes no sense at all
that we
that my motivation for max motivation
for example
is we don't need to learn how to play
instruments at all let's just get up
here and look cool and get a crowd in
right here and like i kind of buy that
but it's also just [ __ ] oh i don't
know that that didn't that didn't hit my
[ __ ] mater you know how like
something's doing so i i'm like that
sort of fell within the arrogance of the
characters for me where i'm like oh
they're just cocky enough and dumb
enough
to think
that they can do it like i think a lot
of people see any kind of per like
whether it's acting or music or you know
juggling stand-up whatever the heck and
think yeah i could do that if i just
tried and it's like yeah but you have to
try for 30 years you know because like
you're
you're going up and so i think
to me it falls within the way these
characters might think which is to be
like yeah i can make a band like how
good do you have to be that scene where
charlie has got the um blanket over his
head he's clearly been huffing uh paint
the entire and you come over to his
house
i remember that shooting that scene it
was the first first shot of season three
that's correct i remember it so vividly
and i remember
me laughing hysterically i remember
nobody else laughing which is all like
in the crew which is always a great sign
because for whatever reason
i i don't know why sometimes there are
things that are very specific to what
we're trying to do and and out of
context but a lot of the crew doesn't
read the scripts so out of context it's
just like what is happening you have no
idea what's happening and it was so
funny to me at the time yeah
i remember
you know so rob rozelle and scott martyr
wrote that episode
and they came up with those lyrics for
the song and it was day man fighter of
the night man
champion of the sun
master of karate and friendship for
everyone and you're like what the [ __ ]
like that's so [ __ ] funny and random
yeah and we had a little casio keyboard
in the office that
you know you could put on the setting
that it fills in the chords you know
so i just like like pressed that one key
was like buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
yeah and then i just started singing the
melody and you started seeing the aas
and that
there was that is
exactly what happened like we were like
let's let's [ __ ] let's see what we can
figure out or whatever and you were like
tinkering with the keyboard yeah and
then you just started kind of singing
the thing and then i did the ah
and i also isn't that from the queen
song well yeah so
flash gordon
it was yeah
at the time um
i was so my buddy sam whitwer who's a
musician um
wanted to do some live performances from
an album that he his
self-published album that he'd put out
and um
you know so
me and some other people were like we
put like a band together and we were
just like we i don't know we only did
like maybe eight shows or something we
were called the crash tones
and what the thing that we opened every
show with was the flash gordon theme
song the queen queen's flash gordon
theme song from the
1980 flash gordon and um
it was like inspired by that for sure
like it felt it felt like
dayman was like
you know like a superhero so it kind of
felt like it it tracked in that or like
it i don't know it made sense it's funny
how music can be like
something's working something clicks
right away and grabs you and it's catchy
and then you find one other
little element to add to it like the oz
and it puts it over the top and it makes
the whole thing work like uh
did you see the documentary on the back
backup singers yeah the woman who for
the rolling stones yeah um
10 feet from stardom or something like
that yeah and they call her like four in
the morning and and they're like it's
like can you come in can you sing these
lines and she's like oh okay rape
it's just the shadow and you're like
well there's that song yeah you know
like it just yeah and then in fact
in that song her voice cracks at one
point and she thought well there's no
way they're gonna use that like let me
do it let me do it again where i i do it
right and phil spector was like nope
that's the one that goes in it's amazing
yeah
just recorded 20 minutes yeah the
creative process is a crazy mysterious
elusive thing
[Music]
well we've got to do another ad because
megan has to pay her rent she has sent
instructions that we must do this so yes
you don't like it blame megan no let's
do it i'm not going to have it
uh guys we'd like you to know that this
podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy
yeah a better help is pretty fantastic
if you have not heard of it it is a
secure online therapy service that
offers video phone and live chat
sessions with a licensed professional
therapist life is [ __ ] hard yeah yeah
yeah
i'm very happy that we're sponsored
by betterhelp online because mental
health is a a very important part of the
the the worldwide discussion i agree i
think uh therapy is uh essential for
people like you go to the gym you work
on your muscles you uh go to the dentist
you fix your teeth and uh sometimes you
need to help your brain too and there's
no shame in that game you know no way no
i feel like like just being here and
being able to talk to you guys is a form
of therapy for me um and so i i would
like to implore people out there if
you're struggling with grief
relationships stress
anxiety i'm seeing a lot of anxiety and
listen i understand sometimes it sucks
to go sit in a waiting room that's an
uncomfortable situation waiting for
someone else before you finish and then
they come out then you're there they see
you it's a whole you know it's an
awkward thing yeah no but you don't have
to do that here because betterhelp
assesses your needs and pairs you with a
therapist in less than 48 hours it's
really hard to find a therapist that
quickly guys and then if you don't vibe
with that therapist you can switch for
free that's huge
you know it's also more affordable than
traditional online therapy that's a big
perk you know because therapy ain't
cheap and guys always sunny podcast
listeners get 10 off their first month
of online therapy at betterhelp.com
sunny that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-dot-com
sunny again right
h-e-l-p yeah so if you guys don't know
how to spell help
then you've got other problems well if
uh for the creeps that are watching they
can see it right there because we're
going to put it on the
screen okay are we i don't know we're
going to put a chiral on there no yeah
we're going to play kyron all right
we'll go check it out and uh you know
tell them we sent ya
[Music]
hey guys
you know what i don't get asked enough
no no what's that
whether or not i shave my balls
really yeah not getting that question
very often no one ever asks you that
like in an interview or anything no no
no like at dinner
when is somebody gonna ask me about my
my balls and whether i shave them or not
and it's always like oh is dennis a
psychopath you know
what's the waitress's name right right
well you're luck my friend because i
think we're gonna get to talk about your
balls for at least a minute right now
yeah yeah yeah okay good yeah yeah
thankfully our new friends at manscaped
the global leaders and below the waste
grooming
uh are sponsoring this podcast and they
have just the thing to keep your weeds
properly whacked
is the ultra smooth package okay a
specialized groin shaving kit to help
you buff shave and protect your nether
regions you know
it's a sensitive subject to talk about
but it's the most important decision you
could make today
yeah ladies and gentlemen
mostly gentlemen uh direct your
attention to manscaped.com and use the
code
sunny
for 20
plus free shipping on the lawnmower 4.0
yeah brand new ultra smooth package
don't you want to be smooth do you want
to be a bear or do you want to be an
otter i want to be an otter i want to i
don't want to be a seal i don't want to
be skinned i want to be trimmed
which i think is fair so you're gonna
have the chance to get that good ball
shine with the ultra smooth package you
know that's that's if you're into that
package if you want ultra smooth you can
get it down there and then you can use
the crop exfoliator all over
so let me ask you something are you guys
shaving your your actual ball sack or
just the top yeah i get again you get
all of it i get it all yeah yeah because
there's some sometimes there's errant
hairs from yeah you don't want yeah you
don't want that situation down there's a
lot of moving pieces down there you know
but that crop exfoliator can help soothe
clear and just keep your your groin skin
refreshed you know what it's actually
great at is reducing ingrown hairs is
that right oh yeah that's not where you
want an ingrown hair no no no no no no
no no no no no you don't want hair
growing into your balls no you want the
hair to grow out and now only and then
you want to take it off
uh with a manscaper yes you want to
remove all the hair finally
boys it's shaving time the crop shaver
has three precision blades with extra
wide lubricating strips and a pivoting
head so no man gets left behind okay
when you hang
dong
all right you get 20
off plus free shipping with the code
sunny at manscape.com that's 20 off plus
free shipping with the code sunny at
manscape.com and say hello to your new
sweet d
you being bob dylan
and singing those lyrics yeah which
that okay so as and maybe i'm maybe i'm
misremembering if if i am please please
correct me
the whole idea of the night man
creeping into your house
coming inside you
and you becoming him
not only were you making all of those
lyrics up at the time but just the
concept of that happening that was not
done in the writer's room that happened
live there was a camera pointed at you
and you were just riffing yeah but so
not only was that really funny
and incredible to come up with in the
moment like that but then we took the
lore that you created
and made a whole musical musical about
it yeah yeah no that was i remember we
just kind of cameras roll
and i had the keyboard it was like no
you just missed it what you specifically
requested you were like let's do let me
just do a couple we just just let the
cameras roll and let me do my thing and
let's just see what happens let's just
see what happens and one of those takes
was
that yeah i remember that was like
first time adam scalina our cameraman
who we've had since season one was like
laughing shaking i had the background
out of the frame yeah you guys yeah you
i remember we had to cut around your
laughter because it was really dumb and
really funny
it's so stupid but it's so funny but so
funny and the way that you were you were
free-flowing and rhyming it all the way
through was
there was no way you had thought about
that no before you stepped up on that
stage i don't i don't know had you i
don't sharing each other like loving
brothers no no no no no i don't think so
that shot of
danny of frank at the end which like
just ends the scene
so funny yeah that look on his face yeah
yeah i don't know that was a ton of fun
i mean that was one of the
like what a great thing we were getting
to do right like
we we made the show
and we sort of were finding our feet and
then we would create these scenarios for
ourselves to be like okay
here's a scenario here's a funny
situation we know this is going to be
lyrics gone wrong
and go
free and and to allow ourselves the
freedom for each one of our characters
or performers to go on the show to be
like all right well just
i don't know turn your brain off and let
it rip
and we've gotten so much good stuff out
of
doing that oh yeah just letting it rip
yeah no yeah well people ask us still
all the time like how much of the show
is improv and it's not really improv as
much as it is like a lot of ad-libbing
and stuff but there are certainly
moments of improv and it's one of the
benefit like
you know for people who are not in the
film and television business they may
not realize like most things
i mean like if you're doing a play
you're doing tennessee williams you
don't change those words like they're
yeah they're they're perfect and they
are the way they are and they're sacred
in a way and so you know you say them
exactly as written
uh tv and film there's usually a little
bit more leeway depending on the writer
and the director right like if it's
quentin tarantino he's probably like no
say it the way i wrote it yeah he's
right there the cohen brothers are aaron
sorkin
brothers right who who just they're like
pretty
word perfect right you got to be pretty
word perfect with those guys although
it's hard to believe that jeff bridge's
performance in big lebowski there
weren't some moments where he wasn't
riffing i heard him talk about it and
they're like no it's all all scripted
out to the um and the uh that's just
that just
shows you how incredible the cohen
brothers are and how incredible jeff
bridges was that it sounds
is that it sounds like you know ad
libyan improvise but john goodman i mean
and yeah that movie is so like unreal
like where he's about to blow up and
then he catches himself like many times
yeah yeah yeah um but like
it's one of the privileges of getting to
do this show is that
because we write it
and we are the creators we don't have to
you know usually with another show like
i would go out of respect for the writer
or the or the show runner i would go and
i would say hey i'm thinking of like
messing with this a little bit like can
we do one where
i just kind of like riff a little bit
you know and i would do that on ap bio
all the time and we eventually got to
the point where mike would just kind of
let me you know do my thing sometimes
but what's happy bio that's a
show that i did on nbc for two years and
then on peacock for two years four years
yeah we did four seasons
sounds cool depending on the movie
depending on the style of comedy
sometimes you can just open it up and
sometimes you can't for our show it
really worked well
to
act it
in a similar style
to how we shoot it right in the cullen
brothers it's very
structured shots you know almost um
a hitchcock-esque in terms of like these
are very stylized the camera's not well
earlier movies the camera's moving
around a bunch but
um with us it's cross-covered things are
dirty they're shot over the shoulder the
characters seem connected it's loose and
you want the comedy to be spontaneous
and loose
and it creates a really good illusion of
reality you kind of really believe these
are real people this is how they talk
and that you're sitting in the room with
them
yeah right where where um
this show on apple that we do called
mythic quest
mythic quest
yeah it's a challenge you're saying
mister with a lisp
mr mister mr west
[Laughter]
cinematic shots every once in a while
and what you realize is people
ad-libbing or improving in those shots
doesn't work for a number of reasons and
sometimes it's subconscious where you
you can kind of feel that they're making
it up
like the shot's clean but the dialogue's
messy and it doesn't work but when we go
to say steadicam or what we do on sunny
which is handheld and kind of rocky and
shaky
then it feels like oh i'm a fly on the
wall i'm not watching a cinematic piece
i'm sitting in the room with those
people and then it works
i don't know i don't know if it's a
conscious thing or a subconscious thing
well i do know that i do know that when
we first created sunny one of the things
that we were
pretty adamant about was cross covering
right i mean it was very inspired by by
the the british office and by curb your
enthusiasm i was convinced that i was
like on curb i mean they're improvising
they've got to be shooting
five cameras at the same time i still
don't to this day really know how they
shoot it but
you know so that was always the idea
from the beginning it was like okay this
is gonna be scripted but i just i want
it to feel
like
the actors don't even know what they're
gonna say next i wanted i just wanted it
to feel really spontaneous i wanted to
feel improvised even if it wasn't
um and you know hence the the cross
coverage and the bad eye lines and the
shitty cameras and
you know but uh the benefit of that was
that we got to
you know do something a little different
i mean
you know some people say that the show
is just us yelling over each other and
they're not totally not totally wrong
i first seen the opening scene anytime
in the early years when you had all five
of us in a room at the same time we're
just talking over each other filling in
each other's lines filling in the gaps
there's no silence no no no god we got
better at that god forbid
yeah but
but the see i think i think so
the scene uh between the two of you when
you find the song
that was clearly covered by
at least two cameras or or maybe three
because there's there's like kismet that
happens where you find the clap you you
were you get into the beat and then you
find the clap at the exact right time
yeah which was and i remember being so
satisfying at the time satisfying in the
edit and then now it's been 15 12 13
years since i've seen it again
it's still satisfying it all feels very
it all feels weirdly real i mean clearly
it isn't because it's so heightened and
so strange you know
although i i bet most people would think
that that song that you made up on the
spot was was was also not not improvised
but it was which is just crazy i also
think going back to the improv thing for
one second like
you know we we never improv like i think
improv the idea of improv is like an
audience full of people and someone says
uh here's the situation peanut butter
jelly and taxes and then they go up on
stage and they create a situation about
peanut butter and jelly in taxes like
that's never what we're doing we ha we
not only do we know the scene we know
what our characters want within the
scene yeah we have it perfectly scripted
to the point where
there's no improv necessary by perfectly
i mean like in our minds you know that
this is good enough we don't want to be
in a situation where we have to improv
and even if i'm doing a song like that
i'm sure i've i have a few ideas going
into the scene about what's going to be
funny yeah it's not so incredibly
spontaneous i mean not to take away from
some good improv but like it's just some
touch points though it's structured
improv it's like
i don't know it's like we really have a
sense of what we want and then we open
it up and say what's the funniest way to
get what we want but again think about
what a privilege it is to to to do that
and and i know that like i mean it's
time to do it because we shot in a way
that's so fast and furious you know you
haven't had a two-hour lighting set up
because you have a crazy dolly move you
know like like here's the cameras go can
you talk about that so well on on
horrible bosses say for instance right
where clearly you guys were riffing and
having fun and all that kind of stuff
and it's a very different shooting
environment where you probably weren't
cross covering a lot maybe occasionally
i don't know i mean but when you've got
like i i don't i mean again with my my
peacock show my very successful four
season peacock show ap bio you know we
would shoot one side at a time uh it's
okay i'll i'll send you the i'll send
you a link ap bio that's such a weird
advanced horrible bosses i know i mean
that was a huge hit
thanks man that was a big hit yeah the
second one
by today's standards the money was right
though
um no i enjoyed the second one
hey man anyway um uh you know where
you're shooting one side at a time yeah
and then you you know you're shooting
one side of a conversation yeah and
you're riffing you're improvising right
and then you've got to stop yeah turn
everything around which takes 20 to 30
minutes to turn all the lights around
come back on the other guy then you've
hope you hope you've got a really good
script coordinator
because then you got to do it on the
other side where it's much tougher to do
it that way yeah i think with horrible
bosses if i remember correctly we did a
lot of three shots
you know and two shots where all three
of us were in the frame yes or it would
be like you know we're getting
interrogated by a police officer the
police officer says the same thing every
time but you guys
open up our end a little bit so
um i think they did a good job of
of where to let let us
dirty up the dialogue and where to keep
it clean but yeah it's much tougher
because i've done a movie the first
feature movie i got to do was going the
distance and
that was my first time on a set where
uh when we were doing that where we
would improvatan you know me and sedakis
and justin long
and then we would have to remember what
we did to turn around to try to yeah
cause we don't do that on sunday no we
just shoot it all at once and and and if
we improvise something
you know we'll we'll usually build on it
or do something different the next time
but either way
you know if you and i are improvising
something we're both on camera at the
same time so when you get in the edit
you get to cut together a scene with all
the actors in it yeah you don't you're
not you know what i mean you're not like
trying to piece together as i mean we do
piece things together but you you don't
have to do it as much on our show on on
mr quest um
mr mr mr quest
do you
yeah how are you balancing that when you
when because obviously you're shooting
it much more like a movie
uh and here's a complete uh this is an
admission that i have nothing to do with
it i've said it before um uh you have
every i we've established this every
time
you've created the characters that
launched them then i walked away and
then you guys have been doing it um but
uh
how are you balancing that uh sort of
like i'm sure you're letting horns be
riff and cut loose so
then when
he comes up with something great and
you've shot one side or you have your uh
script coordinator writing down the
improvs and we do but because um
because david has so much experience i
have so much experience we all in this
room have so much experience you kind of
remember what works and what doesn't but
sometimes we'll say okay remember to get
this we do we do have certain scenes
that we realize we have to cross cover
because
the improv is important and then we have
actually we have other actors too
who aren't as necessarily comfortable
and it doesn't mean they're not great
it's just not they're fantastic on the
show they just they just would rather
stick to the script yeah and if you
throw out something they're happy to say
it but they're it's not their first
instinct to do so here's an interesting
thing
how do
online comments affect you guys
personally
uh i love i i
look i think
i have no problem like i'm not one of
those people who's like no i don't know
i don't ever read reviews of stuff that
i do you know some some actors like you
i can't read that stuff it's too toxic
or whatever
uh whether it's good or bad um i i'm not
that way i it's like i weirdly want the
feedback i like the feedback
now look if someone if someone said
something got on your skin to sit with
you for a few days or like no no no no
it'll it will sit with
uh it could sit with me for a couple
minutes but then it's gone you know now
i will admit however if if after we did
an episode after an episode of sunny
aired or whatever and i if i went on
twitter
and the vast majority of the comments
were negative
sure that that's gonna mess up that
would [ __ ] with me that would [ __ ] with
me but you know most of them are really
good and then there's the occasional
you know something like man your show
has not been good since season six you
know you're just like
thanks for the feedback man
yeah yeah what about you rob you seem
unfazed by these kind of things um
no i think i'm actively unphased meaning
like i'm doing well it's a practice it's
a practice yeah yeah i would say
yeah yeah it never feels good to have
somebody criticize you in some way but i
think you just look at who it is that's
doing so so if you were to come in and
say
hey i don't think what you're doing is
good i would listen to that because i
value your opinion uh but if it's just
some sorry i meant both of you but i was
looking at you you look directly at me
i was using subconsciously ignored it he
asked the question he asked the question
okay all right but both of you guys this
is what we do all the time if you came
to me and said hey we
either see this creatively or your
behavior or whatever it might be or we
have a professional issue with you which
we've navigated over the years uh then i
take that very seriously because i value
your opinions um but if i look on
twitter and it's just some rando
[ __ ] who wants to chime in i don't
get flying [ __ ] yeah but mostly because
i just simply don't i don't know who
they are yeah so i don't value their
opinion right
and then if in terms of criticism the
only time i get because i do read
reviews for new things that come out i
haven't read a sunny review in forever
but
but i but i do read reviews say for mr
quest and
uh the only time which are all very good
the the only time i get upset is when i
feel
that they're lazy
that they're that they're not
understanding what it is we're trying to
do because they they're stupid
and lazy and
sometimes we'll get criticism where i
bring it to megan and dave and i say i
think they're right
but this is somebody who's taking the
time to actually look and
try to understand what we're doing they
have an opinion about it and then
regardless of what their opinion might
be if if
they point out that oh i believe the
show was going for this and they failed
and here's why
and they're right from my perspective
i'll bring it to them and say hey i
think we can be that's valuable well any
any feedback that allows you to make
something better is is is valuable yeah
um and that's different from trolling
which is just very different yeah very
different um uh you know i i've often
been frustrated we've talked about this
you know off camera many times but uh
by reviews of sunny even positive
reviews of sunny where they talk about
the show in a way that makes it sound
unappealing to people
who might be turned you know they're
like they're like man these guys are so
funny and they
they cross the line and it's so gross
and they're disgusting and you know
they're perverts and all this kind of
stuff and it's like
if you don't know the show and you're
reading that review mm-hmm you're gonna
go totally this is not my time
somebody just sent me an article
yesterday that we were on a top ten list
of i there were two shows that i am a
part of that were on a top ten best
office comedies of all time sunny was
one of them and mythiques was one of
them this is said of all time the
mythicquest
piece started like this
we're like number five in the list
mythic quest isn't for everyone
yeah that was the first thing to start
it's god damn it yeah
and i'm like wait wait and this is just
a review it's a positive review yeah but
you're saying it's almost like you're
hedging yeah
like the person that wrote it is saying
i believe that this is a great show but
you might not and i want to make sure
that i have a healthy distance by saying
yeah well it's not for everybody i
warned you i warned you now here's my
opinion [ __ ] off it's like the comments
and the reviews if they hit something
that you have a personal insecurity
about
ah then it stings right like i think for
me if it's like something about my voice
or whatever or
like your looks or whatever like that's
that [ __ ] you're like ah [ __ ] ouch why
did i read that you know um the other
side of it is like [ __ ] you is what i
sound like and i'm aging what do you
want you know like
but it's hard to like build that up when
it's about the work yeah that i don't
know it all sucks [ __ ] everybody
you heard that you heard it here folks
[ __ ] everybody
we'd like you to know that today's
episode is brought to you by helix sleep
ah helix sleep makes some of the
absolute best most comfortable
mattresses out there and they come to
you right in a box and i know what
you're thinking how good can a matrix
out of a box be a pretty freaking good
okay well listen guys sleep is very very
important to me personally um especially
considering that i actually struggle
with sleep so i'm very happy
uh to have a brand new helix mattress to
sleep on and that they gave it to me for
free because that's cool yeah but they
won't give it to them oh sorry that they
that i paid for
yeah and sleep on
helix has an online quiz that matches
your body type and sleep style to the
perfect mattress for you well i know for
me i sleep uh i run hot
you run yeah i run a lot and
helix mattresses are very specifically
designed to account for people like me
that's right yeah i've had my helix
mattress for about a week and i got to
say i love it you know what else was
awesome the unboxing of it oh you enjoy
the actual process yes that's an
important criteria for me in any
mattress and you know it's soft enough
but it's also firm enough helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
sunny that's right guys go get
yourselves the number one best overall
mattress of 2021 from gq
oh yeah gq said that okay and wired
magazine and the mattress many leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine use as their go-to we're
talking about a super fantastic mattress
situation who's not gonna want that yeah
to what degree can you say the wrong
thing
now
like to what degree yeah i think it
depends on probably who you are and what
that thing is but
and what you said and what your
intention was what your intention was
hopefully that does matter
sometimes it doesn't matter in the
immediate and the immediacy reaction to
something but then
right you can walk up and smack someone
in the face and yell at them but if you
do it at the oscars yeah
it's gonna
you're gonna have some blowbacks if you
do it at the after party probably
probably gonna be fine
he should have waited till the after
parties what you're saying of course i
think the audience recognizes what we're
doing who we are and what we're doing
yeah in terms of the television show i
don't think we've done or said anything
here today no i think in this day and
age more than ever you know you're
you have
a lot more coming at you and a lot more
to sort of dance around and think about
but to some extent you also have to just
kind of
press on yeah you know
yeah i i worry for our kids like growing
up in a social media world like like i
like yeah you know
obviously our children aren't famous
people but
you're famous within your school right
you're famous within your circle like
you're you know
mikey of of the three mikes in fourth
grade or whatever
like and you know the group of kids like
tweeting or
anything goes around mikey [ __ ] his
pants and it and then it gets like
posted and it goes around like these how
did how are people navigating it well
probably in the same way
i mean at least the way we're navigating
it would be this in a similar way just
on a larger scale but it's the same
thing which is creating an armor
essentially that that is impenetrable
but not
not able to
yeah but i don't want to walk through my
life with an impenetrable armor okay
like that's like some
crazy [ __ ] well that i don't mean it
from like a like a
sociopathic way um because you know like
sociopaths walk around and they have an
impenetrable armor that you can't
actually get to them because they don't
feel anything
i mean more about your own
value
meaning that you have a sense of self
and who you are and what your value is
to yourself and how much you love
yourself and there's nothing that can
penetrate that now that's active work
that's not something you just feel it's
something you're constantly reminding
yourself of
and i think that's fair and i think from
there you can allow people in into your
heart through that armor if you so if
you so choose to but if they try to come
at you and you don't want them that's
what the armor is for i think yeah look
i mean i i think it comes from your
parents but for the most part it comes
from you know
having parental support
i i really do believe i mean i know
that's what it is for me you know any
time i've ever you know come up against
um sort of like you're not good at this
or you can't do this
thing
you know i i personally believe that
you know my parents belief in me and
their unconditional love
um but ultimately don't you believe that
what that created in you is not a need
for parental love because oftentimes
that's what can happen right where if
you're still looking for external
validation which we all are to a certain
extent but but it will hit a wall where
it you can't you can no longer look look
to that you have to look inside that's
right right and but but because you have
that and you felt safe at an early age
yeah you started to create that that
self worth yeah that you take well it's
almost like you you ultimately you can
go out into the world and be brave and
make mistakes and screw up and not do
things right
much more easily if you know that
there's a place where you can go back to
if you had to where you are loved and
accepted for who you are yes um if you
don't have that love and acceptance
anywhere
um i think it's extraordinarily
difficult because it's hard to go out
into the world and take risks without i
feel that about you guys i feel that way
about this show
so i feel so confident about going out
and doing
whatever it is that i do mister quest or
a movie or another tv show or a business
whatever it might be what movie because
i know
[Laughter]
you're gonna move out of space
when has he ever done a movie i i
haven't and i don't plan to in the
future but the point is that if i were
to be frustrating to me i wouldn't be
afraid
i'm not
i'm not as afraid to fail because i know
i have a home that i can come back to
and that you guys
love me unconditionally but you put me
in check right there's boundaries and
there's discipline to our relationship
but at the end of the day i know you
love me i know you value me and because
of that
i can go out and do other things and if
they fail i go [ __ ] it i got my guys
yeah no you're right i feel that way too
i absolutely feel there's a
there's a great film called um
oh [ __ ] i think it's called the great
beauty it's an italian movie
uh i think he won best form film a few
years ago
uh oh
you told me about this yeah uh i never
saw it uh a spoiler here this is a
spoiler so plug your ears if you plan to
watch italian films
uh which i think most of our fans aren't
but there's this old like nun character
and uh she looks like 170. i mean i
don't know it's probably makeup but she
looks very old she's only got a couple
teeth
and she's always like eating roots
and uh there's some you know some
character says oh she always eats roots
and then at the end of the movie the guy
says to the nun he's like you know it's
like sister why are you always eating
roots and she turns and she looks at him
and she goes i don't speak italian but
so they're like
you know because roots are important
uh and it's a really powerful moment of
the film where you're like oh yeah [ __ ]
if you're not rooted in something
then yeah then all the comments and all
the all the noise all the [ __ ] noise
the [ __ ] mower outside whatever it is
it all comes at you
you need to be grounded and rooted in
something which i also appreciate that i
feel like i've gotten from you guys and
this this show you know where it doesn't
come from where eating root vegetables
fruits
they're nasty that's a yeah um
almost out of coffee and uh i'm sure
that everyone is out of patience so yeah
why don't we wrap this up we talked
heavy
[Music]
you